damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um die
Raffinerie Schwedt Anfang 2023 werden ja
die Ölimporte aus Russland gestoppt und
dann könnte es schwierig werden für die
Raffinerie genügend Rohöl zu bekommen
deswegen haben Deutschland und Polen nun
eine gemeinsame Absichtserklärung sich
darauf geeinigt in Zukunft soll dann die
Raffinerie über den Hafen in Danzig auch
Rohöl bekommen es gibt allerdings jetzt
auch schon Kritik dass das kaum reichen
wird damit die Raffinerie weiter
arbeiten kann trotzdem ist es ein erster
eine erste Lösung nach Monate lang
Verhandlungen bevor diese Verhandlungen
zu diesem Zwischenergebnis gekommen sind
gab es allerdings schon mehrere Anträge
der Opposition und diese sind nun Grund
auch für diese Debatte die Linksfraktion
hat einen Antrag gereicht die
afd-fraktion drei Anträge und auch die
cdu/csu-fraktion und für die
Linksfraktion wird nun als erstes
Christian Goerke sprechen der Sprecher
für Finanzpolitik
Liebe Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Bundeskanzler hat am 23
März hier im Plenum folgendes gesagt die
zitiere Sanktionen dürfen die
europäischen Staaten nicht härter
treffen als sie russische Führung das
ist unser Prinzip Zitat Ende das stimmt
das stimmt auch bei vielen Sanktionen
nur nicht beim Thema Energie und schon
gar nicht beim Öl wenn bocot russischen
Pipeline Öls schneiden wir uns da muss
man einfach das so klar sagen ins eigene
Fleisch denn Aggressor putin wird trotz
aller Umstellungsprobleme sein Öl an den
Mann bringen bzw Abnehmer finden es gab
im Europäischen Rat einen einstimmigen
Beschluss
dass das embaro nur für schiffsöl gilt
aber nicht für Pipeline Öl um die
Energiesicherheit unter anderem anderer
Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union
Slowakei Tschechien Rumänien Bulgarien
zu entsprechen die PCK Raffinerie in
Ostdeutschland steht jetzt vor einem
hausgemachten Fiasko weil diese
Bundesregierung freiwillig ohne bis zum
heutigen Tag Alternativen zu haben davon
abweicht und das ist nicht nur
unverantwortlich meine Damen und Herren
und ich spreche sie auch als
Wirtschaftsminister Herr habe ich an sie
haben sich auch hier regelrecht verwandt
aber
vielleicht ist Ihnen die Entscheidung ja
auch deshalb so leicht gefallen weil die
verbliebenen Importmengen russischen
Erdöl sich möglicherweise ausschließlich
auf das PCK konzentrieren und ich sage
es mal ganz deutlich
und behaupte hätte diese Raffinerie in
Wilhelmshaven gelegen hätte es diese
politische Entscheidung nicht gegeben
meine Damen und Herren
meine Damen und Herren wir sind jetzt
wenige Tage und ich sage wenige Stunden
vor diesen embargo beginnen und das muss
man sich mal vorstellen die
angekündigten Ersatzlieferungen aus
Polen Kasachstan sind bis jetzt nicht
garantiert und deshalb ist unsere
Forderung als Linksfraktion dass sie
sich der EU-weiten Regelung eine
Übergangsregelung anschließen die ist
jetzt dringender denn je meine Damen und
Herren ich höre immer wir haben noch die
rückfallposition wir haben ja die
Pipeline aus Rostock diese Röhre und das
ist der Flaschenhals der gerade mal und
das wissen alle 50% der Kapazitäten ab
und sie hatten Durchmesser meine Damen
und Herren von 40 40 cm das ist der
Durchmesser und das ist keine Pipeline
meine Damen und Herren und die wird auch
das pC kann nicht durch die zwei Jahre
bringen und deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass das PCK am Netz bleibt und vor
allen Dingen die versorgen gesichert
wird wer in Berlin
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Brandenburg
Kraftstoffe tankt wer mit dem Flieger
vom ber abhebt wer seine Wohnung noch
mit Heizöl heizt wird zu 95% im Osten
95%
vom PCK
versorgt und dazu kommt dass ein Drittel
des bitums in Deutschland für den
Straßenbau sind wir sehr kommen das PCK
ist eine kritische Infrastruktur meine
Damen und Herren und deshalb brauchen
wir diese Übergangsregelung um die
Versorgung
von tausenden Arbeitsplätzen auch der
Zulieferanten und Zulieferer aber vor
allem auch die Brücke und deshalb in
meiner Appell an die Grünen die Brücke
in die grüne Raffinerie die brauchen wir
und deshalb brauchen wir diese Zeit
meine Damen und Herren für eine sichere
Zukunft reicht es nicht nur die
Fördermittel jetzt hier ins Schaufenster
zu stellen es braucht zusätzlich eine
vollständige staatliche Kontrolle des
PCK auf der Grundlage des
energiesicherungsgesetz und da meine ich
nicht die teuer ähnlich wie bei Jupa
safe muss das PCK in Bundeseigentum
überführt und damit auch verstaatlicht
werden nur so könnte man auch den
Beschäftigten eine langfristige
jobgarantieversprechen und vor allen
Dingen mit dem Polen wirklich
erfolgreich über Ersatzlieferung
verhandeln meine Damen und Herren Frau
Präsident ich komme zum Schluss viele
Menschen in meiner Heimat Brandenburg
haben schon einmal eine Welle der die
Industrialisierung erlebt und das sage
ich Ihnen das prägt
und die Menschen in Schwedt und in der
gesamten Region brauchen jetzt
verlässliche und machbare Antworten
nicht irgendwann sondern heute vielen
Dank
so weit Christian Görke hat gesagt seine
Heimat ist Brandenburg er war
Finanzminister in Brandenburg von 2014
bis 20 19 und
wir werden noch mehr ausbrannten Burg
hören denn der Wirtschaftsminister hat
sich hier auch schon angekündigt hier am
Rednerpult jetzt allerdings ist im
Markus Hüpfer für die SPD-Fraktion hat
keine Ressource die
Industriegesellschaften des 20 und 21
jahrhunderts so sehr geprägt wie Erdöl
es war das zentrale Lebenselixier der
fossilen Industriegesellschaft wenn
gleich seine Bedeutung heute zum Glück
abnimmt ist und bleibt es weiterhin eine
unglaublich wichtige Ressource für
unsere Gesellschaft
egal
egal ob Benzin diese Kerosin
Flüssiggas Bitumen oder Fernwärme unsere
Gesellschaft ist nach wie vor auf der
schwarze Gold und die Produkte daraus
angewiesen
in Deutschland wird Erdöl in 18
Raffinerien verarbeitet und die brauchen
ständig neues Öl per Schiff per Zug per
Pipeline und weil Deutschland selbst
kaum über Erdöl verfügt müssen wir den
Großteil importieren zum Beispiel aus
den USA aus Kasachstan aus Norwegen und
bis Ende dieses Jahres auch aus Russland
dazu muss man wissen dass dieses Öl
unterschiedliche Qualitäten besitzt
deswegen ist es so schwer einfach mal
eben von einem Öl aus andere umzustellen
das Erdöl aus Russland ist zum Beispiel
besonders schwefelhaltig und die
Raffinerie PCK Schwedt ist auf dieses
schwefelhaltige Erdöl eingestellt es
gibt aber noch eine andere Besonderheit
in Schwedt die Raffinerie bekommt nicht
nur russisches Erdöl nein sie ist auf
direktem Wege mit Russland verbunden
zum einen über eine Pipeline und zum
anderen über den Mehrheitseigner das ist
nämlich nach wie vor der russische
Konzern Rosneft dessen Anteile sind zwar
unter Treuhandverwaltung gestellt aber
das wissen wir alle das ist nur eine
vorübergehende Lösung die Raffinerie in
Schwedt ist eine Lebensader für
Deutschland und insbesondere für die
neuen Bundesländer und deshalb gehört
sie in europäische Hände
deswegen verhandeln wir intensiv mit dem
zweiten großen Eigentümer Shell sowie
der polnischen Regierung dem wichtigsten
Partnerland in dieser Frage die
Eigentumsverhältnisse von Schwedt sind
alles andere als eine Provinz Posse
sondern vom zentraler Bedeutung für die
Energiesicherheit in unserem Land
Erdöl das ist das schwarze Gold der
Vergangenheit es ist aber nicht das Gold
der Zukunft der Goldstandard der Zukunft
ist klimaneutral und grün und er wird
aus Schwedt kommen
wir wollen die Raffinerie nicht nur
sichern sondern sie auch transformieren
und die Arbeitsplätze sichern das was
sie nicht wollen
in der Zukunft nutzen wir diesen
Hochtechnologiestandort nicht mehr um
fossiles Erdöl zu verarbeiten nein die
PCK Schwedt und die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter vor Ort werden zur
Lebensader einer klimaneutralen und
sicheren Energieversorgung in unserem
Land
ich denke dabei vor allem an die
Produktion von Wasserstoff die
Abscheidung und Speicherung von CO2 und
die Produktion grüner synthetischer
Kraftstoffe all das brauchen wir in der
Zukunft all das kann Schwedt in der
Zukunft liefern ich glaube vielen unter
uns ist gar nicht klar
Schwedt ist kein nerviges Anhängsel der
Vergangenheit Schwedt ist der
Herzschrittmacher unserer industriellen
Zukunft
und mit Blick auf die Anträge der Union
der Linken und der AFD
kann ich daher sagen Herr Görke was sie
fordern Entlassungen verhindern die
Transformation begleiten die Belange der
neuen Bundesländer berücksichtigen die
Erdölversorgung sicherstellen all das
wird bereits umgesetzt und wir sind
sogar schon einen Schritt weiter und
deswegen werden wir ihre Anträge
ablehnen
markus hümpfer war das für die
SPD-Fraktion und der nächste Redner ist
Sepp Müller der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der Unionsfraktion
hier im Deutschen Bundestag
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Sozialdemokraten
es gibt Dinge im Leben die kann man mit
einem Koffer voller Geld nicht kaufen
das ist einerseits die Liebe die Liebe
eines Mannes oder einer Frau das ist
andererseits die Zustimmung zu einer
Staatsform und das ist drittens
Vertrauen und warum ihnen und ihrer
ampelregierung und insbesondere dem am
Handy spielen den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
die Menschen nicht mehr vertrauen kann
ich Ihnen sagen
der Bundeskanzler hat entgegen 20
Länderchefs ein nationales embargo zum
31.12 auf dem Weg gebracht
und ihr Bundeswirtschaftsminister Herr
Habig sie haben Zusagen gemacht die sie
nicht eingehalten haben
im April dieses Jahres haben Sie
bezüglich der rohölversorgung der
raffiner Raffinerie Schwedt ich zitiere
gesagt diese Alternative ist eine
Aufgabe der nächsten Tage
sie haben es versprochen wir Habeck sie
haben es gebrochen sie haben Vertrauen
zerstört im Juni im Juni diesen Jahr
dieses Jahres haben sie sich auf die
Bühne in Schwedt gestellt per Handschlag
versprochen dass eine rohölversorgung
garantiert ist dass die Arbeitsplätze
garantiert sind und dass die
Infrastruktur ausgebaut wird sie haben
es versprochen sie haben es gebrochen
sie haben das Vertrauen vor Ort
verspielt meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
nun könnte es uns als größter Opposition
natürlich freuen wenn die Regierung die
Zustimmung deutschlandweit mittlerweile
verloren hat und auf einen Tiefpunkt ist
es könnte uns freuen dass die Ampel
fertig hat aber ich sage nein
nein nicht persönlich freut es nicht
denn ich liebe unsere Ostdeutschland ich
liebe Deutschland unser gemeinsamer
Heimat und ich sage Ihnen Ihre
vertrauenssprüche der Ampel treiben die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nach rechts und
Linksaußen weil sie das Vertrauen fort
zerstören weil sie die Honigtöpfe
hinstellen damit rechts und Linksaußen
Nektar saugen können weil sie die
Brandbeschleuniger derjenigen sind die
am Ende das Kreuz machen bei denjenigen
die unsere Demokratie als Staatsform
ablehnen weil die Menschen Ihnen vor Ort
nicht mehr Vertrauen meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren
und ab 1.1 diese nächstes Jahres droht
thronfolgende Schlagzeilen kein Schritt
mehr in Ostdeutschland Flugverkehr an
Hauptstadt kommt zum liegen tausende
Wohnungen bleiben kalt riesige
bitumenlücke lässt Straßenbauer
verzweifeln und damit ist nicht so kommt
haben wir Ihnen unseren Antrag vorgelegt
denn wir brauchen erst Lösungen und dann
kann es zu einem Embargo kommen gegen
den ergressor aus Russland wir brauchen
zuerst die Pipeline die zusätzliche
Pipeline zwischen Rostock und Schwedt
wir brauchen zuerst eine belastbaren
Vertrag zwischen Polen und Deutschland
wir brauchen zuerst die Sicherstellung
von Sprit und heizölversorgung
deutschlandweit und vor allem wir
brauchen jetzt einen Krisenstab in der
Kommune mit dem Katastrophenstab damit
ihr Fernwärmeversorgung in Schwedt
sichergestellt werden kann
und da ich ja die ersten Zwischenstufe
schon höre und sie uns ja anscheinend
nicht vertrauen schenken vielleicht
hören Sie den von uns gemeinsam
gewählten Bundespräsidenten zu der auf
seine osttur war während seinen letzten
Interview im MDR in der letzten Woche
bezüglich Schwedt folgendes gesagt hat
ich zitiere dass solche Raffinerie wenn
wir uns unabhängig von russischem Gas
und russischem Öl machen betriebsfähig
bleibt ausgelastet bleibt das muss auch
der Politik in Berlin klar sein nehmen
Sie die Worte des Bundespräsidenten an
wenn Sie wie wir Deutschland lieben wenn
Sie wie wir die Demokratie
verfächten und weiterhin als unsere
Staatsform haben wollen dann nehmen Sie
die Sorgen und ernst und Nöte der
Menschen im Osten ernst und stimmen Sie
für unseren Antrag es ist ihre letzte
Chance gerade in Ostdeutschland für
Vertrauen zu sorgen sie haben so viel
Vertrauen zerstört und korrigieren Sie
Ihre Haltung stimmen Sie unserem Antrag
zu
Sepp Müller hat hier deutlich kritisiert
dass seine Meinung nach die
Versorgung mit Öl nicht gesichert sei
für die Raffinerie in Schwedt Michael
Kellner der Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär im Wirtschaftsministerium
hat da mit Polen verhandelt und kann
sich nun dazu äußern meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren keine einzige
Industrieanlage in unserem Land hat mich
dieses Jahr so beschäftigt wie das PCK
Schwedt die Treuhand im September sie
war notwendig um dort die Situation zu
stabilisieren ohne die Treuhand wäre
Schwedt aus der Produktion
herausgegangen wir haben damit Schwedt
stabilisiert wir haben nicht nur das
getan sondern wir haben ein großes
transformationspaket auf dem Weg
gebracht wir haben ein das Herzstück
dieses transformationspaketes ist ein
750 Millionen Euro schweres GW
Sonderprogramm und ich war ihnen als
Abgeordnete im Deutschen Bundestag sehr
dankbar dass es noch gelungen ist in dem
Haushaltsverfahren für 2023 dieses
Sonderprogramm abzusichern uns erst am
Dienstag hatten wir den GRW
Koordinierungsausschuss und alle 16
Bundesländer haben diesen GAW
Sonderprogramm zugestimmt das ist ein
beeindruckendes Zeichen gesamtdeutsche
Solidarität herzlichen Dank an alle
Länder dafür
wir haben als Bundesregierung gemeinsam
mit den Ländern eine
Arbeitsplatzgarantie nicht nur abgegeben
das war mir ja besonders wichtig weil
wir wissen nicht nur 1200 Arbeitsplätze
sagen ganze Familien hängen da in der
gesamten Uckermark dran und wenn sie
sich den Betriebsplan für die Hitze für
das nächste Jahr anschauen dann sehen
Sie dass dieses Versprechen umgesetzt
wurde und die Arbeitsplätze sicher sind
[Applaus]
wir haben mit der Transformation
begonnen die so lange verzögert wurde
und grüner Wasserstoff wird ab 2025 in
Schwedt produziert werden ich danke
allen Beteiligten auch und gerade
herzliches Dankeschön an Brandenburg an
Wirtschaftsminister jörg Steinbach
[Applaus]
dieses Jahr war nicht leicht doch eines
ist auch klar auch im kommenden Jahr
wird in Schwedt Öl verarbeitet aber und
das ist die entscheidende Nachricht des
Tages kein russisches mehr
wir haben rostlift Deutschland
angewiesen für Januar kein russisches
Rohöl einzukaufen wir setzen damit die
Ankündigung der Bundesregierung um Herr
Staatssekretär erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage des Kollegen Ernst ich
komme erstmal zum Ende der Ausführung an
dieser Stelle weil ich glaube es ist
wichtig zu hören und zu verstehen
wir setzen damit die Ankündigung der
Bundesregierung um die dafür notwendige
Voraussetzungen sind erfüllt die
Versorgungssicherheit kann durch
Lieferung über Rostock Polen und
Kasachstan gewährleistet werden der
Markt hat die vergangenen Monate genutzt
um sich zu wappnen und flexibler
aufzustellen auch für das PCK ist damit
die von einigen lieb gewonnene bequeme
Abhängigkeit von einem Standbeinen ein
unzuverlässigen russischen Holzbein auf
drei Lieferwege diversifiziert worden
das erhöht Resilienz und
Reaktionsmöglichkeiten denn die sichere
Versorgung mit Benzin Diesel und Heizöl
ist und bleibt die oberste Prämisse der
Bundesregierung in dieser Krise für die
Unternehmen und für die Familien vor Ort
sie wissen
wir haben roßnew unter Treuhand gestellt
und eine gemeinsame Vereinbarung mit der
polnischen Regierung unterzeichnet mit
diesem Rückenwind war ich vergangene
Woche in Warschau und habe intensive
Gespräche mit der polnischen Regierung
den pipeline-betreibern und PK in Orland
geführt im Ergebnis haben wir jetzt die
Zusage der polnischen Seite ab Januar
ausreichende Ölmengen zu liefern die der
PCK eine komfortable Auslastung von rund
70% ermöglichen
ich danke ich danke der polnischen
Regierung für die intensive
Zusammenarbeit und begrüße weiter das
Engagement polnische Unternehmen in
Deutschland denn nur gemeinsam können
wir versorgen Sicherheit für Polen und
Deutschland gewährleisten in einem
gemeinsamen europäischen Binnenmarkt
dazu kommen Verträge mit Kasachstan die
die Auslastung der Raffinerie weiter
steigern und zu guter Letzt haben wir
die Lieferung über die Pipeline Rostock
Schwedt die ein stabilen mindest
Durchsatz garantieren die entsprechenden
Schiffe zur Vollauslastung der Pipeline
Rostock Schwedt sind von den drei
Anteilseignern bestellt und werden ab
Januar in den Hafen Rostock einlaufen
ich danke an dieser Stelle ausdrücklich
schnell enie und total die von sich aus
für Neuner und Schwedt ihrerseits schon
lange angekündigt haben auf russisches
zum ersten Januar zu verzichten und die
hier gemeinsam mit der Bundesregierung
alles für die Versorgung Sicherheit
unseres Landes tun
gemeinsam mit der mineralwirtschaft
finden wir Lösungen die es in
Unternehmen ermöglichen sich von
russischen Öl zu befreien um
gleichzeitig die ausreichende Versorgung
mit sicherzustellen und im Betrieb in
Schwedt und in Leuna vorzuführen das
Ziel ist es die Auslastung von über 70
Prozent im Januar im Laufe des Jahres
weiter zu steigern wenn sich die neuen
Bezugsquellen im kommenden Jahr
eingespielt haben diese durch Wladimir
Putin erzwungene Umstellung weg von
russischen Öl ist ein Kraftakt bei dem
es auch mal ruckelt aber insgesamt ist
es möglich und richtig denn so machen
wir unsere Energieversorgung
unabhängiger und robuster deshalb setzen
wir aus dem aus dem Ausstieg aus
russischen Öl vollständig um und sichern
das rechtsverbindlich in Brüssel ab
Polen wird diese Schritt gemeinsam mit
Deutschland gehen angesichts des Krieges
in der Ukraine gegen die Zerstörung von
Stromleitungen und die ukrainische
Zivilgesellschaft zu terrorisieren ist
das ein richtiges und notwendiges Signal
für manche im Haus mag eine politische
Begründung nicht ausreichen auch aus
Gründen der Versorgungssicherheit ist
dieser Schritt notwendig denn ganz zu
Recht wollen viele Firmen keine Produkte
aus russischen Öl abnehmen und viele
Dienstleister keinen Service für das PCK
anbieten wenn sie nach dem ersten Januar
weiter russisches Öl verarbeiten würde
herzlichen Dank
Michael Kellner hat hier noch einmal
verteidigt das Vorgehen der
Bundesregierung und nun gibt es eine
Kurzintervention von Klaus Ernst aus der
Linksfraktion
Energie diese Fragen gehörtet sie haben
viele Vorschläge gemacht sie haben viele
Absichtserklärungen gegeben aber die
Frage ist jetzt konkret was ist
vertraglich abgesichert mit Polen
gestern nee gestern den Wirtschaft
sind Energie wurde vom Staatssekretär
Wenzel gesagt das ist noch nicht klar
ist und es wurde gesagt dass es noch
nicht klar ist weil eigentlich Polen
drauf besteht dass Rosneft enteignet
wird das ist bis jetzt nicht geschehen
und ich möchte jetzt von Ihnen ganz
konkret einmal nach fünf sechs Monaten
ganz gibt es einen geschlossenen Vertrag
ist der abgeschlossen und wie viel
Kapazität haben sie vereinbart was wird
konkret geliefert über Polen und die
zweite Frage sie haben von Kasachstan
gesprochen auch darüber diskutieren wir
lang im Wirtschaftsausschuss im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
ebenfalls haben sie den bitteschön nun
irgend diese sagen können
welche von den Kasachen
nach Schwedt geliefert wird irgendeine
konkrete Zahl und keine
Absichtserklärung und drittens ist
eigentlich geklärt mit Russland das ja
wenn ich das richtig geographisch sehe
muss ja das Öl von von den kasacken
durch die fußballleitung gelaufen sonst
kommt ja bei uns an haben Sie irgendeine
konkrete Vereinbarung mit den Russen
damit das Gas auch bei uns ankommt
wissen Sie ich bin so langsam leid
sieben acht Monate Absichtserklärungen
zu hören und wenn man nachfragt dann
bleibt immer unkonkret
Herr ernst bleiben Sie bitte stehen wenn
Sie eine Antwort haben möchten Herr
Staatssekretär sie können darauf
antworten
was er nicht auf sie zugehört haben Herr
Ernst ich habe ja gerade gesagt dass wir
die Zusicherung der polnischen Seite für
eine Auslastung von der PCK in Schwedt
von 70 Prozent ab Januar
2023 haben wir haben zugleich
zugleich haben die Anteilseigner der PC
kam eigene Verträge mit Kasachstan
verhandelt die weitere Mengen ab Januar
2023 ermöglichen und ja wir haben immer
ein Risiko das Leitung unterbrochen
werden sie brauchen ja nur die Zeitung
aufschlagen denn lesen Sie von
explodieren und ja deswegen war es so
wichtig dass wir in den vergangenen
Monaten uns auch darauf vorbereitet
haben dass wir in jedem Fall in jedem
Fall auch den Falle der Störung der
Zuleitung dass wir die Auslastung auf
einer Mindestmenge sicherstellen können
deswegen habe ich ja gerade erläutert
dass die Schiffe für den Hafen Rostock
bestellt sind und Sie können sich im
Januar in den Hafen Rostock stellen und
die Schiffe zählen dort kommen sie an
wir garantieren also das in Schwedt
weitergearbeitet werden kann
[Applaus]
vielen Dank und wir führen die Debatte
fort und der nächste Redner für die
afd-fraktion ist Carsten Hilse und
Carsten Hesse ist der energiepolitische
Sprecher seiner Fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute noch im Mai dieses
Jahres gab der
wirtschaftszerstörungsminister vormals
Kinderbuchautor der erstaunten deutschen
Öffentlichkeit bekannt dass sich
Deutschland dem Öl Embargo gegen
Russland auch per Pipeline
anschließen würde zum
31.12.2022 und rein ideologisch denn
genau der Bezug von Öl per Pipeline war
bei den EU Sanktionen für alle
ausdrücklich ausgenommen als ihm klar
gemacht wurde dass die Ostdeutschen
referenerien voran das PCK Schwedt dann
die Produktion einstellen müssten was
sie Versorgung mit Kraft und
Schmierstoffen und chemischen
Vorprodukten Produkten in ganz aus
Deutschland zusammenbrechen lassen würde
schickte er seinen nicht minder bedingt
begabten Kellner vor der den entsetzten
später dann das blaue oder eher das
grüne vom Himmel versprach Rohöl käme
auch weiterhin nach Schwedt wenn auch
vorerst in geringerer Menge die Jobs der
rund 2000 Beschäftigten würden per
Jobgarantie gesichert und krönte das
ganze dann mit dem Satz Zitat die
Lichter gehen hier nicht sofort aus was
nichts anderes heißt sie gehen dann eben
später aus und dieser Zeitpunkt scheint
jetzt gekommen denn keine der gemachten
Versprechungen wurden erfüllt weder
wurden die ersatzöllieferung per Vertrag
mit Polen gesichert noch die
entsprechenden Transportwege für die
benötigten Mengen gebaut eine
vergleichbare rohöl-qualität für spät
ist momentan nicht lieferbar lediglich
die Jobgarantie also Geld für nicht tun
wurde wohl auf dem Weg gebracht aber
sicher ist auch das nicht mit anderen
Worten die grüne Bundesregierung hat das
gleiche geplant und durchgeführt wofür
die Staatsanwaltschaft Neuruppin jetzt
Mitglieder der Klima Terroristen der
letzten Generation als kriminelle
Vereinigung einstuft
diese unter Anklage stellt und
Hausdurchsuchungen bei den
klimatterroristen durchführt begründet
wird das vorrangig mit den wiederholten
Versuchen die rohölversorgung des PCK
schweetz zu stoppen also exakt dasselbe
was die Bundesregierung tut die
Staatsanwaltschaft Neuruppin begründet
ihr vorgehen damit es ginge auch um die
Bildung und Unterstützung einer
kriminellen Vereinigung nach Paragraph
129 Strafgesetzbuch und die Gruppe Weise
eine klare Rollenverteilung und eine
kontinuierliche Struktur auf hier sind
die Ähnlichkeiten nicht rein zufällig
der einzige Unterschied ist dass die
Bundesregierung die Exekutive eines
Rechtsstaates ist dieses Recht aber mehr
und mehr umdeuten ja missbraucht in
diesem Zusammenhang sei ein Papst
Benedikt erinnert der den Abgeordneten
vor gut 11 Jahren hier im Bundestag wenn
auch in einem anderen Zusammenhang die
Worte des heiligen Augustinus ins
Stammbuch schrieb Zitat nimm das Recht
weg was ist dann ein Staat noch anderes
als eine große Räuberbande Zitat Ende
und recht hat er aber es gibt auch etwas
Positives offensichtlich haben die
Mahnungen an die konservativen Kräfte in
der Union für ein teilweises Umdenken
gesorgt denn ihr Antrag der heute hier
zum pezika Schwedt eingebracht wird
bemängelt nicht nur das Fehlen von
ersatzmengen in geeigneter Qualität und
sofern Preisen sondern vor allem den
Mangel jeglicher Rechtsgrundlage für das
Embargo das Embargo und alle sanktionen
müssen also weg dass dies mit dieser
Regierung möglich ist halten viele
Bürger für ausgeschlossen sie halten
diese Regierung eben weil sie aufrecht
und Gesetz pfeift für eine Zitat große
Räuberbande der einzige Weg vernünftige
Politik für Deutschland zu machen ist
wenn sich endlich die konservativen
Kräfte wie in meinem Heimatkreis Bautzen
in dieser Woche geschehen
zusammenschließen im Kreistag stimmte
fast die gesamte CDU-Fraktion für einen
Antrag der AFD freiwillige
Integrationsleistung für abgelehnte
Asylbewerber zu streichen und damit dass
den Haushalt zu entlasten und zweitens
den Magneten für asylforderer
herunterzudrehen dieses Beispiel macht
hoffentlich Schule in ganz Deutschland
für Deutschland vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Karsten Hilse war das für die
afd-fraktion und nun hat
des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers
Bundesminister für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz heißt und nicht Bundes zur
Wirtschaft zerstörungsminister das ist
unparlamentarischer Begriff und darum
bitte ich Sie in Zukunft darauf zu
verzichten
nach einem Hinweis von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Yvonne mag was
an dieser Stelle und nun kommen wir zum
nächsten Redner das ist Konrad
Stockmeier für die FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und vor allen
Dingen Kollege Görke
wenn man ihnen zuhört dann weiß man
wieder warum es gut ist dass die
Energiepolitik in diesem Lande nicht in
der Verantwortung der Linkspartei steht
weil sie wirklich noch in
ost-west-konflikten der 1990er Jahre
verhaftet sind die müssen sie mit sich
ausmachen ich finde in diesem Hause hat
es eigentlich nicht mehr viel Platz und
ich habe mich an dieser Stelle ich habe
mich an dieser Stelle über die Arbeit
des Bundesministeriums für Wirtschaften
Klimaschutz an der einen anderen Stelle
durchaus auch kritisch geäußert aber
eine Polemik die sie gegen Minister
Habeck hier ausgebreitet haben die
möchte ich wirklich zurückweisen als sie
gesagt haben na ja wenn das PCK Schwedt
beispielsweise in Schleswig-Holstein
wäre dann hätte er sich anders darum
gekümmert das ist wirklich äußerst
billige Politik und ich möchte Sie daran
erinnern dass eines das eines der neuen
LMG Terminals auch in Lubmin angesiedelt
ist also gut dass sie in der
Vergangenheit bleiben aber nichts mit
der Zukunft zu tun haben zweitens
Kollege Müller aus der Unionsfraktion
sie breiten hier große Tiraden vom
Vertrauensbruch aus den angeblich die
Ampelkoalition an den Menschen in
Ostdeutschland begangen hat
also ich mache mir dieses Gerede ja
nicht zu eigen aber wenn ich mir noch
mal vor Augen führe auf welche massiven
strategischen Fehlentscheidungen die
Tinte zurückzuführen ist in der wir hier
jetzt sitzen weil nämlich
Bundesregierungen an denen die Union
maßgeblich beteiligt war oder sie sogar
geführt hat rein Weise zu
Eigentumsverhältnissen in der deutschen
Energieversorgung geführt hat die uns
jetzt auf die Füße fallen dann frage ich
Sie was eigentlich die
größenvertrauensbrüche der Vergangenheit
waren denken Sie mal darüber nach
und damit sind wir beim nächsten Punkt
die Bedeutung des PCK Schwedt für die
Kraftstoffversorgung in Ostdeutschland
die ist ja unbestritten aber sie
schlagen hier einen Tonfall an wo ich
mal gerne wüsste wie gehen sie damit
eigentlich nach Polen
Polen weiß sehr genau aus seiner
Geschichte warum ist mit großen
Anstrengungen die völlige Unabhängigkeit
von russischen Energieimporten anstrebt
und jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt wo es
uns vielleicht mal gut zu gesichtsstünde
und davon eine Scheibe abzuschneiden und
da sind wir wieder bei dem was ich hier
Mantra mäßig immer wieder verkünde die
Lösung dieser Probleme eben auch in
einem partnerschaftlichen europäischen
Kontext zu sehen zusammen mit den
Ländern die wissen was Freiheit bedeutet
denken Sie darüber nach
[Applaus]
an der AFD ist mal wieder völlig
vorbeigegangen das fordern sie in
irgendeinem ihrer Anträge das an
Ertüchtigungen der Infrastruktur
bitteschön gebaut werden soll das ist
seit Monaten im Gange vielleicht einfach
mal die Nachrichtenlage verfolgen
für die Freien Demokraten kann ich an
dieser Stelle noch sagen dass wir es
sehr begrüßen und auch froh darüber sind
dass die Gespräche der Bundesregierung
mit der polnischen Seite jetzt zu den
Ergebnissen geführt haben die Staat
Kellner hier heute verkündet hat das
eröffnet wertvolle Perspektiven für das
PCK Schwedt die Anstrengungen die noch
vor uns liegen die sind unbenommen aber
der Weg in die Zukunft ist
gekennzeichnet so geht man durch die
Krise und nicht mit den Polemiken die
hier von allen möglichen Seiten zu hören
sind vielen Dank
der nächste Redner ist hier auch sehr
bekannt
Jens Spahn stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender für die
Unionsfraktion liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen im September am Kanzler und
Minister versprochen die Versorgung wäre
gesichert der Schritt zum embargo wäre
gut vorbereitet und organisiert auch
heute hier wieder große Worte und
Versprechungen zehn Wochen später muss
man sagen nichts Genaues weiß man nicht
erstmalig jetzt eine Zahl gerade eben in
dieser Debatte nachdem der Kollege
Staatssekretär gestern im Ausschuss
jedenfalls keine nennen konnte oder
wollte hören Worte über Transformationen
Wasserstoff alles richtig synthetische
Kraftstoffe die Ampel redet wenn es um
Schwedt geht viel über die Zukunft aber
sie sollte erstmal die Gegenwart
meistern weil um die nächsten Wochen
geht es jetzt
und da müssen wir einfach mal genau dann
schauen wir doch mal genau hin beim
Gegenwart meist dann kasachstan ist
angesprochen worden es hieß als Ersatz
für russisches Öl könnte welches aus
Kasachstan kommen klang wie eine gute
Option aber wenn Öl aus Kasachstan
kommen soll wenn man das will dann muss
man sich auch darum kümmern da steigt
man Minister Staatssekretär in den
Flieger nach Astana und verhandelt Frage
an die Bundesregierung wer hat überhaupt
mal mit der Regierung in Kasachstan
gesprochen es gab einen Brief des
kanzleramtsministers ansonsten kein
aktives politisches bemühen auf
Leitungsebene im Kontakt mit Kasachstan
so jedenfalls sieht politisches
Engagement in dieser Frage nicht aus
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wie viel wie viel Öl aus Rostock oder
Danzig kommen könnte wissen wir bisher
nicht wir haben jetzt gerade die 70
Prozent gehört aber bis jetzt ich kenne
keine schriftliche Vereinbarung die wäre
uns ja sicherlich ansonsten auch mal
bekannt gemacht worden es ist schon
bezeichnen für sich genug dass die Ampel
heute hier keinen Antrag keinen Plan
vorlegt wie sie denn zum ersten ersten
die Versorgung sichern will gar nichts
schriftlich haben wir bis jetzt von
Ihnen bekommen und so wissen wir heute
knapp zwei Wochen gut zwei Wochen vor
Ende des Jahres bevor dieses politische
embargo in Kraft treten soll aus guten
Gründen um das klar zu sagen wissen aber
wir nicht wissen die Menschen in der
Region nicht wissen 1.200 Beschäftigte
nicht was denn dann gilt ab dem ersten
wie viel steht konkret an Menge ab dem
ersten aus welchen Quellen zur Verfügung
und ist droht ja vielleicht nicht
Versorgungsengpässe kann auch sein aber
mindestens das Risiko von
Preisunterschieden zwischen
West-Deutschland ist ziemlich hoch mit
allem was wir etwa beim Diesel aktuell
sehen und daher werden wir liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie als Union
an ihren Versprechungen messen 70
Prozent im Januar ist ja jetzt eine sehr
sehr klare Aussage an der man auch
messen kann wir werden wenn es sein muss
jedes einzelne Schiff das im Hafen von
Rostock einfährt zählen das können sie
gerne lächerlich machen aber das macht
eine konstruktive Opposition sie misst
eine Regierung an ihren luftigen
Versprechungen
Jens Spahn war das und damit kommen wir
nun zu Jörg Steinbacher wurde schon
angesprochen der Wirtschaftsminister in
Brandenburg
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Abgeordnete die Bundesregierung
vertreten durch das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat für die
Zusammenarbeit mit Brandenburg aber auch
mit Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und
Sachsen-Anhalt eine Bund
länderprojektgruppe zusammengerufen die
unterdessen mehrfach getagt hat und nach
intensiven Verhandlung mit der
Projektgruppe hat die Bundesregierung am
16.09 22 das zukunftspaket Sicherung der
PCK und Transformation in den
ostdeutschen raffineriestandorten und
Häfen zu beschleunigen vorgelegt
dieses zukunftspaket regelt auch
eindeutig Zuständigkeiten so liegt
primär das Thema Versorgungssicherheit
beim Bund und das Thema Transformation
bei meinem Bundesland und entsprechend
fokussiere ich mich auf den zuletzt
gelernten Bereich
Herzstück des Maßnahmenpakets ist ein
Sonderprogramm im Rahmen der GRW mit
Zuständigkeit des
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und
zusammen mit den drei Bundesländern mit
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Sachsen-Anhalt
und uns werden hier umfassende Gelder
sofort bereitgestellt es wurde bereits
gesagt
[Applaus]
dass der Bund 375 Millionen Euro zur
Verfügung steht und die Länder die
andere Hälfte finanzieren
dieser Weg lieber Herr Görke die
Transformation über die GRW zu
unterstützen begrüßt das Land
Brandenburg ausdrücklich Herr Minister
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage des
Kollegen Sepp Müller wenn ich den Satz
zu Ende gesagt habe gerne da ist die
Forderung von Unternehmen ermöglicht was
bekanntlich in einem
strukturstärkungsgesetz wie was für die
Lausitz haben nicht möglich ist jetzt
gar
Herr Minister Steinbach vielen Dank dass
ihr heute hier am Bundesrat als
Vertreter im Bundestag als Vertreter des
Bundesrates reden auch als
landeswirtschaftsminister für das Land
Brandenburg und die Zukunftsvision für
Schwedt machen die wir glaube in der
Mehrheit auch Teilen es geht uns aber
insbesondere um das Thema Gegenwart und
sie haben die tats Force angesprochen
die am 16.09 die Entscheidung getroffen
hat ich frage Sie ganz konkret wie
können Sie eine Zukunft gestalten wenn
die Gegenwart keine 100-prozentige
rohilfeversorgung vorsieht wissen sie
mehr als die 70%, die wir kennen ich
frage sie zweitens Herr Minister was
antworten Sie Ihrer Landrätin Carina
Dirk aus Schwedt was antworten Sie Ihre
Oberbürgermeisterin in Schwedt was
antuten sie dem zukunftsbündnis und Frau
Dr Fischer wenn Sie die Forderungen
haben erst Lösung für 100%
rohölversorgung und dann das Embargo
welche Antwort haben sie darauf
vielleicht können Sie uns an ihren
Erkenntnissen teilhaben lassen
die Frage von Sepp Müller aus der
Unionsfraktion
wir haben und ich selber habe im
Wirtschaftsausschuss meines Landes
mehrfach gesagt dass der Beginn
vermutlich nur abgestützt ist über
Rostock only und ich bin dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium für seine
Anstrengung ausgesprochen dankbar dass
zum ersten Januar die Versorgung von
Schwedt nicht nur auf Rostock only
beruht sondern die zusätzliche Lieferung
aus Polen jetzt realisiert worden ist
zweitens
ich habe mehrfach die Debatte miterlebt
was bedeutet die über 100 Prozent zu
reden die der derzeit die Leistungsstand
dieser Raffinerie liegt bei 85 Prozent
85 Prozent entspricht sozusagen 100%
Wiederherstellung des jetzigen Zustands
und damit sind wir mit 70 Prozent davon
nicht mehr weit entfernt und ich bin
optimistisch dass auch die Verhandlung
mit Kasachstan gelingen werden um diese
letzte Lücke wieder zu schließen
und die letzte Antwort die ich Ihnen
dazu gebe und ich brauche ich meine
Bürgermeisterin in Schwedt nicht zu
geben weil die meiner Meinung ist
sondern das geht mir in Richtung von
Frau dog
ich erinnere an der Stelle an den
strukturwandelprozess in der Lausitz
und mir kommt alles wie ein Dejavue vor
wo an der Stelle der Weltuntergang für
die Lausitz pro von denselben
Oppositionsparteien proklamiert worden
ist wie er heute hier geäußert worden
ist für Schwedt wir sind in zweieinhalb
Jahren mitten im Transformationsprozess
der Lausitz und dieses sollte den
Menschen in Schwedt Mut machen das
Schwedt eine Zukunft hat und dass es uns
dort genauso gelingt die Transformation
zu gestalten wie in der Lausitz
[Applaus]
damit war vorhin mit dem Paket war
verbunden die Beschäftigung in der PCK
mit geeigneten Maßnahmen zu sichern was
gelungen ist und die Regelungen zur
einkommenssichung der Beschäftigten in
dieser Form ist einmalig und
uneingeschränkt positiv hervorzuheben
und zusätzlich stellt der Bund Geld zur
Verfügung für die Ertüchtigung bzw für
die sicherere Versorgung über den
pipeline-betrieb und ich bin dem bmwk
ausgesprochen dankbar mit welcher
Intensität an einer auch wirtschaftlich
auskömmlichen Versorgung gearbeitet
worden ist und auch weitergeht wird und
ich möchte mich auch bei dieser
Gelegenheit und ich bitte das den
Vizekanzler weiterzugeben mich
ausdrücklich beim Bundeskanzler bedanken
angesichts dieser Unterstützung möchte
ich hier die Gelegenheit wahrnehmen und
nicht bei Ihnen ganz persönlich für die
Unterstützung der Bundesregierung zu
bedanken wir wissen dass es erst ein
erster Schritt ist dass wir uns nicht
zurücklegen dürfen dass wir weitermachen
müssen aber für diese erste
Unterstützung unseren ganz herzlichen
Dank auch von einem Minister
im Telegramm steht bei der laufenden
Zeit wir haben ergänzend von Seiten des
Landes eine Förderung von Schweden im
Rahmen der sogenannten
ghb-experimentierklausel ermöglicht so
dass wir bereits jetzt fünf Millionen
der Stadt zur Verfügung stellen können
im Dezember um den anschließenden
Transformationsprozess das Thema Flächen
Generierung Bereitstellung und der
zugehörigen Konzepte zu realisieren wir
haben von der Seite der
Wirtschaftsförderung unseres Landes ein
Verordnung eingerichtet dass für alle
potenziellen Ansiedler entsprechend eine
Andockstation ist und wir haben zur
engen Begleitung des ganzen
Transformationsprozesses eine Task Force
und der Leitung meines
Ministerpräsidenten eingerichtet die am
Montag wieder Tagen wird und die sich
speziell um die Themen
Standortentwicklung und
Genehmigungsverfahren kümmert
lassen mich mit einer persönlichen
Bemerkung an der Stelle schließen es ist
wichtig in der Region dass die Menschen
den Mut behalten und insofern sollten
die Ergebnisse die in diesen neun
Monaten erzählt worden sind nicht
schlecht geredet werden sollen sie
sollten den Menschen Mut machen Schwedt
hat eine Zukunft und die Landesregierung
ich kann hier nicht für die
Bundesregierung anmaßen hier zu sprechen
aber die Landesregierung steht weiter
bei den später danke schön
so kündigt ist der Wirtschaftsminister
Brandenburgs an Jörg Stein macht ihr
hier im Bundestag gesprochen hat nächste
Redner ist Rainer Kraft für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
ja geschätzte Präsidentin Werte Kollegen
zuerst in kurzer Realitätscheck in der
vergangenen Nacht die Leistungsdaten der
Kraftwerke Solar 0 Wind 5GB kennen die 4
GB Gas 18 und Kohle in Summe 30 Gigawatt
von dieser Stelle ein herzlichen Dank an
die Arbeit in den Kern Kohle und
Gaskraftwerken ihr haltet die Republik
am Laufen Winter und Sonne tun es nicht
und werden das niemals schaffen
seit einem halben Jahr war es nun die
Bundesregierung dass ab 1 Januar eine
Unterversorgung der raffinerin in
Schwedt bevorsteht unter dem halben Jahr
heißt es immer nur dass man mit Polen
verhandelt nun geht's Hürde heute eine
Lösung präsentiert wir werden sehen was
dabei rauskommt aber er ist nicht da
weil sie die Wirtschaftsministerium
nicht abnehmen ist das wenn man die
Treuhänder hat man nicht in Lage zu
sagen welche Verträge ab 1 Januar für
diese raffinierten das nämlich hier
nicht ab und Lösungen wurden von Seiten
Lösungen wurden von Seiten des
Ministeriums für eine Lösung in
Eigenregie ohne Polen der niemals
präsentiert man verlässt sich immer
darauf dass eine Pipeline gebaut werden
soll die vielleicht in zwei Jahren
fertig sein soll aber in
Berlin-Brandenburg kann das ja schon mal
länger dauern und mal kurz zur
Erinnerung vor 74 Jahren wurde Berlin
fast ein Jahr lang ausschließlich über
die Luft versorgt doch zwei und vier
motorige Propellermaschinen und diese
Ministerium schafft es nicht eine
einzige raffineriestandort mit Pipeline
mit Bahnanschluss und mit Binnenhafen
Natur versorgen und wäre diese Regierung
vor 74 Jahren die Verantwortung gewesen
ja Berlin wäre verhungert
der die AFD fordert jetzt dass die
Regierung einen Plan vorlegt ein Konzept
dass die Raffinerie zu 100% über
deutschen Boden versorgt werden kann und
zwar mit den vorhandenen Transport
Ressourcen
bahnpipeline und Schiff und nicht mit
irgendeiner wünsch dir was irgendwann
Pipeline und wir sprachen vom verhungern
ja das wird das Schicksal des
industriestandes Schwedt sein in den von
der Regierung versprochenen blühenden
wasserstofflandschaften am Tag in
Schwedt werden geh mal Daumen 750
Gigawattstunden
Industrieprodukte verarbeitet schauen
wir was wir bräuchten um das im
Wasserstoff abzubilden für diese Mengen
an Strom für die Elektrolyse bräuchte
man dann in Schwedt entweder 22
Kernkraftwerke oder 90 bis 95.000
Windkraftanlagen nur von den Strom für
diese elektrolyseure
und an diesen Zahlen sieht man es ganz
deutlich die wasserstoffpläne der
Regierung sind grüne Märchen und weil
mit Wasserstoff in Schwedt nur ein
Bruchteil der bisherigen Wertschöpfung
wird stattfinden können wird auch nur
ein Bruchteil der Arbeitsplätze dort
erhalten werden können und für die
Menschen entweder nicht in diesem grünen
Märchen erfreuen nein sie werden zum
zweiten Mal in ihrem Leben einen
bitteren Bruch ihrer Lebensplanung
erdulden müssen
die Regierung schafft also keine Ersatz
für die 1200 produktiven Arbeitsplätze
in der hart arbeitenden Menschen in der
Raffinerie und das Versprechen eines
Erneuerbaren Zukunft es ist bereits vor
Beginn des Unternehmens gebrochen worden
und ja es ist die gleiche Lüge
kommenden Landschaften
[Applaus]
die Meinung von Rainer Kraft unter
anderem Obmann im parlamentarischen
Beirat für nachhaltige Entwicklung der
afd-fraktion und nächster Redner ist nun
Bernhard Herrmann für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen hier im Deutschen Bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lassen Sie mich herzlichen Dank sagen
Ihnen Herr Wirtschaftsminister dr
Steinbach aber auch an Staatssekretär
Kellner und mein Kolleginnen
Abgeordneten die zur Versachlichung
beitragen und beigetragen haben denn nur
so konzentriert arbeitend Dank ans
Ministerium an die Ministerien und
gleichzeitig sachlich kommunizieren
werden wir dieser Herausforderung und
diese Aufgabe gerecht jetzt anstehenden
und auch der langfristig anstehende
Zukunftssicherung
aber noch einmal klar und deutlich
die Versorgung mit Erdölprodukten ist
gesichert in Westdeutschland und ebenso
in Ostdeutschland am ersten Januar wird
das in Bago auf Erdöl
aus Russland in Kraft treten das nutzen
einige und unnötige enge um unnötige
Ängste zu führen dabei sind wir schon
heute auf das vorbereitet wie wir heute
gehört haben auch in Ostdeutschland wird
man nach in Kraft treten des in bares
genügend Öl haben um in ausreichenden
Mengen diese Benzin Heizöl für alle in
Ostdeutschland zu produzieren die es
brauchen
schauen wir uns einmal die Realität in
den beiden ostdeutschen raffinerinnen
mit Teil an beide haben zu Beginn des
Jahres nahezu ausschließlich Rohöl aus
Russland verarbeitet Leuna hat sich im
März entschieden sich von Russland
unabhängig zu machen und irlos anderen
Quellen zu nutzen inzwischen hat Leuna
seine Versorgung erfolgreich komplett
auf andere Lieferanten umgestellt die
PCK in Schwedt braucht und erhält mehr
Unterstützung bei dieser Umstellung um
die PCV ist der Abhängigkeit Russland zu
befreien hat das bmwk roßneft unter
Kontrolle gestellt und so von Putins
fossilem Klammergriff befreit
ermöglicht dass nivellierte
energiesicherungsgesetz dass der
Bundestag als Antwort auf die
Energiekrise umfassend reformiert hat
der energiehafen Rostock wird ausgebaut
und die Pipeline Rostock später tüchtigt
um mehr Öl vom Hafen in Rostock
transportieren zu können die Kosten
dafür übernimmt vollständig der Bund für
zusätzliche Mengen hat heute
Staatssekretär Kellner gerade von den
erfolgreichen Verhandlungen mit Polen
und den gut laufenden Gesprächen mit
Kasachstan berichtet so dass im
folgenden Jahr die Vollauslastung
wiedergegeben sein wird
es ist entscheidend und das scheint
ihnen als Union egal das ist bitter das
wäre also Europa zusammenhalten und eben
mit Polen kooperieren das scheint ideal
und das macht Sorge zum Glück haben sie
zurzeit unter der Stelle nicht zu sagen
in einer schwierigen Gemengelage ist die
Produktion von PC der PCK gesichert dank
der beharlichen Arbeit der
Ampel-Koalition und insbesondere des BMW
Gras auch wenn die PCK Schwedt
übergangsweise nicht vollständig
ausgelastet sein könnte in den ersten
Monaten 23 kann mit den Raffinerien
Leuna und Schwedt der Bedarf an
Ölprodukten in Ostdeutschland problemlos
gedeckt werden denn wir haben bei
wichtigen Infrastrukturen genügend über
Kapazitäten um genau solche Fälle zu
bewältigen es wird genügend Öl Produkte
geben und wer was anderes behauptet
führt nur unnötig aber wohl aus ganz
anderen Gründen ganz gezielt Ängste in
der Bevölkerung ebenso werden
Befürchtung geäußert dass die Preise für
Ölprodukte regional steigen könnten aber
schauen wir doch mal die aktuellen
Preise an die Tankstellen von Berlin
werden überwiegend von der PCK Schwedt
ich habe eben heute mal nachgeschaut
heute liegen die Benzinpreise in Berlin
wir an die meisten Tagen deutlich unter
dem Bundesschnitt die Preise in
Ostdeutschland werden auch bei einer
vorübergehenden gewissen Reduktion der
Produktionskapazitäten in Schweden in
Schwedt stabil bleiben
Ölprodukte lassen sich gut
transportieren sie würden einfach aus
anderen beschafft es gibt also keinen
Grund zur Sorge über plötzliche
Preissprünge bei Kraft-
die Sorge der Beschäftigten der PCK und
in der Stadt Schwedt hingegen verstehe
ich nur zu gut Erfahrungen mit dem
Verlust von Arbeit von gewohnt denn
Entwurzelung das haben wir im Osten in
meiner Generation vor 20 bis 30 Jahren
gemeinsam massiv erleben müssen die
Folgen wirken oft bis heute noch nach
auch deshalb hat die Ampelkoalition
anders als sie damals ein großes
zukunftspaket für die PCK in Schwedt
geschnürt um die Arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und den Industriestandort und
Menschen in der Region zu halten und um
wichtige Zeichen für die Zukunft der
Region zu setzen für das Jahr 2023 ist
sichergestellt dass es aufgrund des
imagus keine betriebsbedingten Kündigung
geben wird alle 1.200 meist gut
bezahlten Arbeitsplätze sind sicher die
große Frage ist doch aber wie geht es in
Zukunft weiter wie klappt es langfristig
und das geht nur klimaneutral die
Ostdeutschen Flächenländer haben enormes
grünstrompotenzial und das ist ein
großer Standortvorteil für
wasserstoffindustrie von der
petrolindustrie
damit diese Chance aber nicht ungenutzt
bleibt unterstützt die Ampel-Koalition
die Transformation der Standorte in
Schwedt Leuna mit dem schon benannten
Programm der regionalen
Wirtschaftsförderung mit einer
dreiviertel Milliarde Euro mit diesen
Maßnahmen stellen wir sicher dass die
PCK Schwedt gemeinsam mit der raffiner
die ostdeutschen Bundesländer heute
morgen und übermorgen mit den
notwendigen Energieprodukten versorgen
wird kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
den Ambitionen der Linken an dieser
Stelle die zukunftsfeste Transformation
der Weg sein muss um auch langfristig
erfolgreich zu sein herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
und der nächste Redner ist Robert farle
Robert fahle ist fraktionslos daher gibt
es hier keinen Applaus
mal sehen wie das nach der Rede aussieht
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
ich halte das gar nicht für falsch was
Herr Spahn hier vorhin gesagt hat dass
man die Tanker alle zählen sollte und
dass man genau kontrollieren sollte ob
das Öl ausreicht
schwebt
ausreichend zu versorgen und diese
Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten
das halte ich für den entscheidende
Aufgabe für alle Leute die betroffen
sind und die zu Recht Angst um ihre
Arbeitsplätze haben und ihren
Versprechungen gar nichts mehr glauben
weil sie wissen dass es nicht Russland
war der dieses Öl abgestellt hat sondern
dass die Grünen schon am Anfang dieses
Jahres Frau Bernburg auf einer Konferenz
erklärt haben das Öl und Gas in Barcode
kommen sollen und das kommt jetzt und
Sie haben nichts geklärt und wie toll
ist denn die Zusage aus einem Gespräch
mit irgendwelchen Leuten in Polen die
uns zurzeit 1,3 Billionen Euro
Reparationsleistungen abverlangen wollen
als Deutschland und kein Wort davon
verlieren dass ein Teil ihrer Gebiete in
ihrem eigenen Staat jemals deutsche
Staatsgebiet ist
wie groß ist das Vertrauen in solche
Gespräche denn diese Frage der
Reparation ist schon ewig lange her und
die wollen die jetzt ernsthaft ernsthaft
in Polen zur großen öffentlichen
Diskussion im Vorfeld der nächsten Wahl
machen
nächstens die von Korruptions Skandal
erschütterte EU hat jüngst einen
preisdeckel für russisches Öl weit unter
dem Weltmarktpreis verhängt wobei
Russland schon erklärt hat dass es zu
diesem sanktionskonditionen nicht
liefern wird so zerstört man
Lieferketten und schädigt die eigene
Wirtschaft und die Konsumenten mit dem
Vorwand des Ukraine Kriegs zum Schluss
sage ich noch eins machen Sie Schluss
mit ihren sinnlosen Wirtschaft Kriegen
gegen unsere eigene Wirtschaft denn sie
schädigen weniger Russland die können
auch nach China und sonst wo liefern
nach Indien von wo dann Deutschland auch
wieder Öl einkaufen kann übertreiben
ja die ist jetzt langsam vorbei ich
bedanke mich
langsam schon sondern Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
bevor ich die nächsten Redner ankündige
möchte ich noch Gäste begrüßen auf der
Ehrentribüne hat die Präsidentin der
Parlamentarischen Versammlung der
Organisation für Sicherheit und
Zusammenarbeit in Europa OSZE Frau
Margareta zederfeld mit ihrer Delegation
Platz genommen im Namen aller
Kolleginnen und Kollegen des Deutschen
Bundestages begrüße ich Sie recht
herzlich hier bei uns
[Applaus]
die parlamentarische Versammlung der
OSZE spielt eine wichtige Rolle bei der
Verhinderung sowie der Lösung von
Konflikten sie ermöglicht den Dialog und
erinnert die Teilnehmerstaaten an die
Einhaltung der in der Schlussakte von
Helsinki eingegangen Verpflichtungen für
ihre Aufenthalt bei uns und für ihr
weiteres Wirken in der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung der OSZE begleiten Sie
unsere besten Wünsche
[Applaus]
und in der Debatte zum PCK Schwedt
ist der nächste Redner für die
FDP-Fraktion Reinhard hugend ist der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher seiner
Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir sind es ja gewöhnt dass wir von ganz
Linksaußen und ganz rechts aus jeden
Versuch
wahrzunehmen um irgendwie
Weltuntergangsstimmung zu betreiben hier
das kommt noch warten Sie ruhig ab aber
ihre Strategie dieses permanente
Untergangsszenario hier darzustellen
unterscheidet sich ihnen nichts von dem
was die AFD tut und das stimmt die
Hufeisen Theorie wiederum ganz genau und
meine Damen und Herren
lieber Herr Müller dass sie dann
eigentlich in das gleiche Fahrwasser
hineingehen das schockiert mich ehrlich
gesagt schon das schockiert mich ehrlich
gesagt schon wenn Sie hier anfangen in
ihren Ausführungen
versprochen und nicht gehalten dann
können wir ja mal ein mindestens
ganztägiges Seminar veranstalten was die
Union schon mal vor Wahlen versprochen
hat und hinterher nicht gehalten hat ich
hätte da so die ein oder andere Idee
dass man in reg Verantwortung nicht
alles umsetzen kann was man im Wahlkampf
verspricht ist vollkommen normal dass
sie aber jetzt die Situation nutzen
ähnlich zu argumentieren wie AFD und
Linke das schockiert mich nun wirklich
sehr und Herr Müller dann hantieren sie
mit falschen Zahlen wir wollen ja auf
den stretche Problem zukommen
komme aus Köln und da gibt es eine große
Raffinerie und wer sich da ernsthaft
hinstellt und sagt wir brauchen
permanent 100% Versorgung einer
Raffinerie hat noch nie begriffen wie
eine Raffinerie funktioniert es tut mir
leid keine Raffinerie braucht jeden Tag
100%
rohölversorgung Köln wird aus Rotterdam
versorgt und es wird täglich
kontrolliert wie viel tatsächlich in
Köln ankommt damit man es vor Ort auch
wirklich verarbeiten kann und nun wissen
sie doch auch Herr Müller
sie wissen genau dass wir
nach dem klar war dass wir kein
russisches Öl mehr beziehen wollen
es Leuna leichter hat aufgrund der
Eigentümerstruktur als Schwedt Leute hat
sich ja relativ schnell aufgelöst es ist
eben dargestellt worden und dann waren
die Bemühungen der Bundesregierung und
haftig schwer genug weil ein Eigentümer
der Haupt Eigentümer von schwebt
eigentlich nur russisches Öl einführen
möchte
und dann haben wir über die technischen
Möglichkeiten debattiert und es war
relativ klar dass wir ungefähr 50% der
Versorgung über Rostock darstellen
können über die bisher vorhandene
Leitung und dann haben alle Techniker
gesagt ja das reicht aber nicht für
einen Betrieb dann ist dann ist
debattiert worden können wir das
Aufheben durch beantragen das könnte
knapp reichen aber es wäre viel
sinnvoller mit den polnischen Nachbarn
darüber zu debattieren deren Pipeline zu
nutzen die Leute ja außerdem auch nutzt
und entschuldige könnten wie können Sie
so etwas sagen
meinen Sie Herr Kellner würde sich hier
in den Bundestag hinstellen und sagen
wir garantieren ab Januar 70% versorgen
und wir halten das nicht durch also das
lieber das kann ich nur wirklich nicht
abnehmen also sie haben das Wort von
Herrn Kellner hier und auf der Debatte
sollten wir meiner Meinung nach
debattieren und nicht irgendwelche hätte
könnte sein Debatten führen die
Bundesregierung hat sich um das Problem
gekümmert es hat lange gedauert ja aber
ich kann auch die ich sage mal
Reserviertheit der Polen in der Frage
auch verstehen es ist ja ausgeführt
worden unabhängig von russischen
Öllieferungen zu werden dass unsere
polnische Nachbarn das ein bisschen
anders sehen als wir wissen wir das
Problem ist gelöst wenn darüber hinaus
über die 70%
Kasachstan als weitere Lieferant
gefunden wird wissen wir es gibt ein
Rechtsrisiko aber meine Damen und Herren
in der Wirtschaft gibt's immer ein recht
Risiko vielen Dank
Reinhard Huben war das damit kommen wir
zum nächsten Redner aus der
Unionsfraktion Markus Reichel spricht
nun
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir sind jetzt in der Zeit von
Weihnachten Weihnachten ist eine Zeit
der Hoffnung des Optimismus allerdings
muss ich sagen
mit der alleine mit Hoffnung werden wir
an dieses Problem nicht herangehen
können Herr Staat Kellner sie hatten zum
Beispiel erwähnt dass ein Ansatz für die
Lösung ist eben kasachisches Rohöl
hierher zu bekommen ich halte es für ein
Prinzip Hoffnung zu erwarten dass sie
das durch russische staatsgebieten
durchbekommen wenn Sie vorher einen
barco erklären ich muss auch sagen zu
dem Thema mit den polnischen Lieferungen
ich hoffe das ist dazu kommt ich muss
allerdings sagen bisher so habe ich
zumindest aus Polen gespiegelt bekommen
ist das nicht in trockenen Tüchern es
mag fortgeschritten sein hoffen wir dass
es soweit kommt ich sag nur mit dem
Prinzip Hoffnung alleine kriegt man
einen Industrieland die Deutschland
nicht durch so eine Krise in der wir
heute sind
es gibt auch keinen Zweifel
3000 Arbeitsplätze in Schwedt alleine
hängen direkt davon ab dass die
Raffinerie ausreichend versorgt ist
es gibt auch keinen Zweifel dass noch
viel mehr Arbeitsplätze eben in den
Zulieferern aber vor allem in den
besorgten in den versorgten Gebieten in
Ostdeutschland daran hängen und
natürlich gibt es keinen Zweifel dass
daran noch eine ganze Reihe von Familien
direkt beteiligt sind und diese Familien
verdienen eben jetzt immerhin eine Woche
vor Weihnachten und zwei Wochen vor dem
geplanten in Kraft treten des Embargos
dass sie klare Ansagen machen und nicht
hier zu Verwirrung beitragen und ich
muss sagen aus den bisherigen
Darstellungen aus der Ampel fragt der
Koalition habe ich eigentlich nur
Verwirrung mitgenommen das geht nicht
wir als Union wir stehen
selbstverständlich zu klaren Sanktionen
gegen Russland aber die müssen gut
vorbereitet sein denn es geht doch um
viel mehr hier jeder Fehler jede
schlechte Vorbereitung führt doch nur
dazu dass wir Arbeitnehmer Bevölkerung
und Unternehmen verunsichern und um das
zu verhindern haben wir unseren Antrag
hier eingereicht indem wir ihnen eine
Reihe von Punkten noch einmal nennen die
hier erfüllt sein müssen und die auch
der Grund dafür sind dass wir sagen ein
Pipeline embargo muss daran geknüpft
sein dass die Voraussetzungen dafür
geschaffen sind und das sehen wir
momentan eben noch nicht erfüllt
was von ihrer Seite bis heute 16 Tage
vor ein krafttretendes Embargos hier
genannt ist damit kommen wir nicht
weiter wie kann genug Öl geliefert
werden nicht beantwortet was passiert
mit den Arbeitsplätzen in Schwedt
teilweise beantwortet aber in den in den
ansonsten noch davon betroffenen
Industrien nicht beantwortet wie gehen
Sie wie lange soll Kurzarbeitergeld
bezahlt werden welche Sicherheiten
können den Menschen gegeben werden nicht
beantwortet wenn sie wirklich ernsthaft
hier Antworten geben würden wollen dann
würden sie mal vielleicht uns die
Ergebnisse aus den Gutachten was sie bei
prognungsjahr offensichtlich in Auftrag
gegeben haben wo sie genau diese Fragen
entsprechend beantworten mit uns teilen
das haben sie in eine Antwort auf unsere
Kleine Anfrage geschrieben dass genau
das dort beantworten soll wieso hören
wir heute hier nicht diese Ergebnisse
und das Problem ist doch und das haben
wir hier doch wunderbar mitbekommen
diese Verunsicherung die dadurch führt
geschürt wird die wird dann bedenkenlos
von Populisten ausgenutzt es kommt doch
nicht von ungefähr dass die AFD in ihren
Antrag aus dem Mai in dem Fall
reinschreibt Formulierungen wie
Massenentlassung das ist genau die
Verunsicherung die sie damit führen so
geht das nicht
und ich sage Ihnen sie müssen sie sind
gefordert natürlich hier in Schwedt
Klarheit zu schaffen sie sind gefordert
dass für die Zukunft zu schaffen haben
sie glaube ich sehr gute Ansätze gar
keine Frage aber ich möchte dann noch
eines sagen in der Lausitz nur als ein
Beispiel da haben sie auch mit ihrer
Floskel dass sie sagen idealerweise ein
braunkohleausstieg bis 2030 wieder genau
dieselbe Prinzip Hoffnung Strategie
angewendet die am Ende unverantwortlich
ist die Verunsicherung führt wir
erwarten zeigen sie mehr Respekt vor den
Arbeitnehmern oder Wirtschaft in Schwedt
in Ostdeutschland dann fingen auch die
Populisten hier keinen Ansatz mehr um
ihre unausgegorenen Anträge die
einzureichen vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
nächster Redner ist Hannes Walter für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Eltern
auf der Besuchertribüne und alle anderen
Gäste vor Ort
wohl noch nie in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat eine
Koalition in so kurzer Zeit so große
Aufgaben zu bewältigen wie in diesem
Jahr und das der russische Angriffskrieg
auf die Ukraine hat massive Folgen und
das wirkt sich auch auf die europäischen
Nachbarn aus die Folgen der Energiekrise
die der Krieg ausgelöst hat bekommen wir
in Deutschland täglich zu spüren
infolgedessen gefährden eine hohe
Inflation und eine Drohne Rezession die
Prosperität unseres Landes diese
historischen Herausforderungen nehmen
wir an die Ampelkoalition über einen
Verantwortung in schwierigen Zeiten
wir gewährleisten Energiesicherheit und
machen gleichzeitig unabhängig von
vielen Energien wir schützen die
Substanz der deutschen Wirtschaft und
treiben gleichzeitig die Transformation
zum klimaneutralen Wirtschaften voran
PCK Schwedt ist ein Brennglas für die
vielen Herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen wir übernehmen daher auch hier
Verantwortung für die Beschäftigten und
für den Standort wir geben Sicherheit
jetzt und morgen das tun wir zum
Beispiel indem der Bund die
treuenlandschaft über PCK übernommen hat
diese Maßnahme war für den Fortbestand
der Raffinerie von großer Bedeutung
nicht nur die Erdölversorgung wird
dadurch langfristig weiter gesichert
jetzt können auch die dringend
notwendigen Investitionen in die Zukunft
des Standortes stattfinden
darüber hinaus sorgt die zweijährige
Beschäftigungsgarantie des Bundes für
Sicherheit bei den Beschäftigten mit den
Beschlüssen der pck-gesellschaft hat zum
betriebskostenbudget können
betriebsbedingte Kündigung für 2023
ausgeschlossen werden damit sind alle
1200 Arbeitsplätze für das nächste Jahr
gesichert wir halten was wir versprechen
vordringliches Ziel ist es jetzt dass
wir den Durchsatz der Pipeline in
Schwedt weiter erhöhen wir werden daher
für die Belieferung die Pipeline Rostock
Schwedt ausbauen die Pipeline soll so
ertüchtigt werden dass zügig eine
stabile jährliche Maximalkapazität von
rund 9 Millionen Tonnen gewährleistet
ist der Boden stellt die nötigen 400
Millionen Euro in einem zukunftspaket
zur Verfügung mit diesem zukunftspaket
sichern wir die raffineriestandorte
Schwedt und Leuna und investieren
gleichzeitig in die Transformation
Ostdeutschlands
Ende November haben wir mit dem Haushalt
2023 die richtigen Weichen dafür
gestellt darüber hinaus und ich danke
ihnen Staatssekretär Kellner für die
guten Nachrichten haben wir mit Polen
die Versorgung gesichert
[Musik]
und
Herr Müller wenn Bürgermeisterin Hoppe
aus Schwedt mit dem mit den Worten ich
zitiere mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin in
die SPD Eintritt die SPD ist die Partei
die sich maßgeblich für Arbeitnehmer
einsetzt und die Arbeitsplatzsicherung
ist jetzt das Wichtigste in der Stadt
dann kann die Arbeit der Bundesregierung
und der SPD-Fraktion nicht die
Schlechteste sein und hier hat auch
Stefan Zierke der Kollege vor Ort ein
erheblichen Anteil dran natürlich ist
auch die Arbeit der Landesregierung hier
von überaus wichtige Bedeutung danke
jörg Steinbach
für die Sicherheit von morgen wird es
maßgeblich auch auf die Investitionen
Zukunftstechnologien ankommen das
zukunftspaket setzt hier genau das
richtige Signal denn es nimmt die
Transformation und Modernisierung in den
Fokus nicht nur in Schwedt sondern in
ganz Ostdeutschland es geht um die
Transformation weg von fossilen
Brennstoffen deshalb ist der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energie der rasche Ausbau
und Betrieb von elektrolyseanlagen und
der zügige Hochlauf einer
wettbewerbsfähigen Wasserstoffwirtschaft
von großer Wichtigkeit daran arbeiten
wir hier in Ostdeutschland schon lange
mit Hochdruck
auch in Zukunft kommt es darauf an Tempo
zu machen und den Anschluss nicht zu
verpassen Sicherheit der Arbeitsplätze
Ertüchtigung und Modernisierung der
Pipeline Rostock Schwedt aber auch
ausreichend Mittel für eine
klimafreundliche und zukunftsweisende
Transformation in Schwedt horstung und
Leuna sind Punkte auf die es ankommt ich
komme zum Ende unsere Botschaft lautet
wir übernehmen Verantwortung wir sichern
unsere ostdeutschen raffinerie-standorte
wir lassen beim Strukturwandel niemand
zurück vielen Dank und Glück auch
Hannes Walter war das für die
Sozialdemokratin und damit kommen wir
hier zum vorletzten Redner in dieser
Debatte das ist Jens Kappen ersetzt im
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
für die Unionsfraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen am Ende dieser
Debatte kann ich ja gerne mal das Fazit
meiner Rede an den Anfang stellen
ohne eine wirtschaftliche ohne eine
technische ohne eine umweltverträgliche
Lösung für die Raffinerie in Schwedt und
alles was damit verbunden ist darf es
kein nationales am WAGO auf Pipeline
gebundenes Ausrufezeichen
in 16 Tagen plant dieser
Wirtschaftsminister plant die
Bundesregierung eine freiwillige
nationale völlig unnötige Ausweitung des
europäischen ölemagus auf die
Erdölleitung druschbar die ja
bekanntlicherweise in Schweden endet
und sie halten an diesen embare fest
ohne gesetzliche Grundlage
die Protokollnotiz des Bundeskanzlers
ist ein Koloss auf tönernen Füßen
weder auf EU-Ebene noch hier im
Deutschen Bundestag wurden da drüber
jemals Beschlüsse gefasst
sie halten daran fest ohne die
Versorgungssicherheit mit Kraftstoffen
in Ost-
sie erhalten an diesen embargo fest ohne
die Absicherung dass die Ostdeutschen
Raffinerien auf Alternativen
Transportwegen vollständig
mit dem benötigten Öl versorgt werden
sie halten an diesen embargo fest ohne
sicherzustellen dass der Straßenbau in
Deutschland
zuverlässig mit Bitumen
beliefert wird der zum größten Teil aus
Schwedt kommt sie halten an diesen
embargo fest ohne Garantien für den
Erhalt von Arbeitsplätzen über das PCK
hinaus und wirtschaftliche Infrastruktur
an den ostdeutschen raffineriestandorten
und sie halten an diesen embargo-
[Musik]
und das geplante Öl embargo würde
hauptsächlich unserer Volkswirtschaft
und die Menschen in aus dem
Mitteldeutschland schaden
sie sollten aber alles vermeiden und uns
zu schwächen und deshalb noch einmal
ohne Lösung darf es dieses nationale
embargo nicht geben kommen sie endlich
zur Vernunft und ziehen sie ihre
Protokollnotiz zurück
diese hat zu viel Verunsicherung gesorgt
und zu Existenzängsten geschürt ihr
Motto seit Monaten es wird schon
irgendwie gut gehen Herbeck das ist aber
zu wenig für eine umsichtige
Regierungsarbeit es reicht eben nicht
aus nur in guten Gesprächen zu sein seit
Monaten nur reden nur Ankündigung nur
unverbindliches bliebe es bei dem
nationalen Öl embargo würde
Ostdeutschland wieder die gesamte Last
zu tragen haben begreifen sie endlich
das Ostdeutschland einen enormen
wichtigen Beitrag für die
Versorgungssicherheit leistet und
wichtig ist für die Wertschöpfung des
gesamten Landes
und die Berichte aus dem
sogenannten Wirtschaftsministerium im
energieausschuss haben die ganze
Planlosigkeit ihres Hauses offenbart
dort ist das Prinzip Hoffnung
vorherrschend aber das ist angesichts
der Lage und der zu befürchtenden
Auswirkung viel zu wenig bevor man einen
nationales Öl embargo ausruft sollte man
vom Ende her denken und sich nicht auf
so dünnes Eis begeben für die Bürger und
viele Unternehmer meine Heimatregion ist
das eine Frage ihre Existenz und ihre
Lebensleistung und deshalb bleibt es aus
der Sicht der Menschen östlich der Elbe
dabei die Habeck jeder Monat ohne Öl ist
ein guter Monat
die Kritik von Jens Köppen war das auch
die Unionsfraktion hat ja einen Antrag
ja eingereicht in dem sie verlässliche
Rahmenbedingungen für die PCK Schwedt
fordert und der letzter Redner ist der
für die SPD-Fraktion tatsächlich dass
wir jetzt eine staatliche Planwirtschaft
einführen dass wir nichts mehr in die
Hände der Betriebe legen sondern dass
der Staat alles zu organisieren hat und
alles selbst beschaffen muss das ist
schon echt ein starkes Stück und
es ehrt sie dass sie sich alle für eine
Standort Schwedt einsetzen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Linken
einige ihrer Forderungen sind
diskussionswürdig andere Teile ich nicht
ich hätte es besser gefunden wenn sie im
Antrag nicht als alte Stereotype aus der
Schublade geholt hätten von wegen der
Bund den Osten vergessen hätte oder den
Westen nicht bevorzugen solle mit
Verlaub dass es echt Quatsch es ist
normal dass die späteren sich anders
fühlt als ein Schleswiger es ist normal
dass die Leute aus Nebra anderen Fokus
haben als Norderstedter es gibt Regionen
in Deutschland das ist das normalste der
Welt die Menschen in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern bis Sachsen sind
in dieser Frage schon längst viel weiter
wir kümmern uns um die Menschen in
diesem Land in Deutschland egal wo sie
leben meine Damen und Herren
ich denke ich kann das guten Gewissens
sagen denn ich bin selbst im sogenannten
Osten geboren Luckenwalde keine 50 km
von hier in Brandenburg das heißt ich
weiß wo die Bedeutung des Raffinerie
Standorts in Schwedt für die Region mit
1200 Arbeitsplätzen ist die Raffinerie
der größte Arbeitgeber in den
unendlichen Weiten der mokkermarkt
hunderte Arbeitsplätze sichert die
Raffinerie noch indirekt in der Umgebung
das haben wir heute alles schon gehört
aber dieser an dieser Standort ist ein
wichtiger Anker der tausende Menschen
ernährt insofern hat das was in Schwedt
passiert auch immer Auswirkungen in der
Breite ich kann Ihnen versichern dass
die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und die
gesamte Ampelkoalition alles dafür tun
wird das Arbeitsplätze und
Versorgungssicherheit erhalten bleiben
durch die Versorgungsstrukturen durch
die Versorgungsstruktur des PCK in
schwedts in Berlin-Brandenburg MeckPomm
Sachsen-Anhalt Thüringen direkt oder
indirekt betroffen und das ist eine
schwierige Situation das stimmt da gebe
ich ihm vollkommen recht aber ich darf
auch im Namen meines Fraktionskollegen
und ostbeauftragten der Bundesregierung
Carsten Schneider sagen muss leider
heute krankheitsbedingt passen wir
kümmern uns darum ja wir sind dran und
ich denke in dieser Frage sind wir uns
hier im Hause weitestgehend einig wir
müssen alle ausbleibenden Öllieferung
nach Schwedt ersetzen wir müssen die
Wertschöpfung erhalten und deswegen ist
es sehr gut dass die Liefervereinbarung
in Polen steht und ein Backup aus
Kasachstan in Arbeit ist
es zeigt sich dass es richtig und
wichtig war dass die Bundesregierung
schon vor Monaten Gespräche mit den
Regierungen mit den anderen Regierungen
eingeleitet hat und die 100%ige
Auslastung eines Betriebs zu garantieren
ist aber übrigens nicht die Aufgabe des
Staates natürlich müssen alle Weichen
gestellt werden die Versorgung
ermöglicht Wirtschaften tut aber immer
noch der Betrieb selbst
und
mit diesen ganzen Mitarbeitern und
Mitarbeiterinnen die diese Betriebe
haben und dem Staat als Rückhalt werden
sie das auch schaffen und wir nehmen
diese Rolle sehr ernst aber was wir vor
allem tun müssen ist dass wir Schwedt
und der gesamten Region Perspektiven
aufzeigen den Menschen Perspektiven
aufzeigen meine Damen und Herren deshalb
ist es gut dass wir nicht nur Anträge
schreiben sondern konkret handelt über
15 Jahre werden 374 Millionen Euro in
die Uckermark fließen Geld das vom Bund
und vom Land Brandenburg kommt vielen
Dank lieber jörg Steinbach dass wir so
gut zusammenarbeiten und dass du heute
hier dein Wort für die Region ergriffen
hast
mit einem Gesamtpaket von insgesamt 825
Milliarden Millionen Euro werden wir die
Region fit machen für die Zukunft das
ist ein riesen Kraftakt das wissen wir
aber hier werden Politik Wirtschaft und
vor allem die Menschen gemeinsam Ideen
entwickeln und die Region voranbringen
das kommt dem Raffinerie Standort zugute
das kommt der Region zugute und das
kommt in Land zu Gute die Raffinerie von
heute wird aber nicht der gleiche
Arbeitgeber von morgen sein so ehrlich
sollten wir uns wirklich machen es wird
auch künftig Arbeit geben aber die
Arbeit wird sich wandern aber der Wanne
ist nichts wovon man Angst haben muss im
Gegenteil ich finde es ein gutes und der
mutigendes Signal das auf dem Gelände
künstliche künftig grüner Wasserstoff
hergestellt werden soll also Wasserstoff
aus erneuerbaren Energien als Bund
schaffen wir dafür die nötigen
Voraussetzung für einen funktionierenden
wasserstoffmarkt beides zusammen denken
also die Gegenwart sichern und die
Zukunft planen das ist die richtige
Antwort die ist sogar so richtig der
Kollege hat das gerade erwähnt dass die
Bürgermeisterin von Schwedt sogar die
SPD eingetreten ist deswegen
schauen wir uns mal den afd-antrag ein
bisschen genauer an das von Zukunft
Ideen natürlich nichts zu finden das ist
klar im Gegenteil Verunsicherung Panik
mache das ist das was sie können sie
reden von Blackouts preisschocks die
Industrialisierung und sie reden dann
heißen Herbst dabei aber haben sie mal
die Tankstellen geschaut die die Preise
die letzten Tage Aussehen diese 1,69
Benzin 161 von drei Wochen waren wir
noch bei 2 €. dabei haben wir schon ein
Embargo für schiffsgestützt Importe aus
russischen aus Russland der Preis Schock
fällt also aus ihre Stromausfälle die
sie dabei reden gerade am Montag war
eine französische Überlastung System hat
die Frequenz im deutschen Netz als
Maximum gebracht und was passiert nix
ihr Blackout fällt aus ihr heißt der
Herbst von dem sie die ganze Zeit reden
der Deckel wie die Energiepreise für
Wörter Verbraucher Gewerben Industrie
entlasten und springen ein wenn die
Leute in finanzielle Schwierigkeiten
geraten schauen sie raus ja heiße Herbst
fällt aus und nun zu ihrer
Industrialisierung die kommt zum Schluss
bleiben wir dabei den Fakten wir haben
runtergehende Arbeitslosenquoten trotz
multiplakriesen offene Stellen in der
Industrie auf höchst und die
lieferkettensituation entspannt sich
derzeit in den Betrieben Kurzarbeit
trotz Energiepreisen auf geringsten
Niveau seit langem ihre die
Industrialisierung fällt aus genauso wie
die Massenentlassung für spätausfallen
werden also
ich komme zum Schluss vielen Dank wir
brauchen keine Schwarzmaler wir brauchen
keine Teufel die an die Wand gemalt
werden wir brauchen eine zupackende
Haltung das werden wir tun so war die
Bundesregierung hier steht und die als
Ampel dafür was tun können
Bert war das für die SPD-Fraktion der
letzte Redner hier in dieser Debatte zur
Raffinerie Schwedt und wie ihr weiter
Arbeiten gewährleistet sehr also werden
kann mit der Rohstoffversorgung